the story broke about Alan Kurdi
drowning and being washed up on a beach
Dave and I were so distressed and and
upset about what was happening and we
knew that we could sponsor a refugee
family and we just decided enough zijn
uh we need to do something to help
enthusiasm and compassion are infectious
and it wasn't long before a lot of other
people were doing the same thing that we
were
slaves of tamannaah bhatia muhabba we
are near Oh Moo of women and immoral
hanana my far the most challenging part
of this has been the worry at the
beginning about making this all work
getting through the red tape and
actually getting the family here it's
it's reassuring to see how much momentum
does have game
you